is the new iPad 10 really worth 450
dollars when you can get an iPad Air 5
for 520 or a refurbished iPad Air 4 for
418. well today we will find out because
we are going to compare everything from
the speakers the displays the cameras
the connection speeds the performance of
the A14 compared to the A14 and the M1
chip in the iPad Airs and much more now
as far as the dimensions they look like
they're the same but the iPad 10 is
actually slightly heavier and slightly
thicker as well as being slightly wider
the iPad 10 is also slightly taller as
well and that is because the bezels are
larger all around and that is due to the
display which we'll talk about in just a
sec both of them have the touch ID
sensor that's larger at the top right
there and both of them have the same
exact cameras on the back as well as the
quality of the front ones but there is
one change we'll talk about now one
thing that did change as far as the
design of the outside is the fact that
the iPad Air both the four and five has
that magnetic connection for the apple
pencil 2 whereas the iPad 10 does not
and the SMART connector is also not on
the back like we have with the iPad Airs
but on the side now now as far as the
displays they actually have the same
exact 10.9 inch LCD display the detail
and the sharpness is identical and both
of them go up to the same 500 nits of
brightness other than that we have two
differences first off the iPad Airs
support DCI P3 colors so you have much
better gradation for uh editing photos
videos whereas Apple locked down the
iPad 10 to srgb the other difference is
that the iPad Airs have a laminated
display so the screen is glued to the
touch surface whereas the iPad 10 still
has a non-laminated display so there's
this air gap between the glass here
which not only makes it so when you're
using the apple pencil you don't exactly
Touch where you see display drawing but
it also lowers down your contrast and it
increases reflectivity honestly this is
one of my biggest disappointments even
though it is less expensive to fix a
non-laminated display you guys see that
difference in contrast and reflectivity
it is pretty massive now the next thing
that I'm very curious about are the
speakers because Apple finally added
serious speakers into the regular iPad
whereas the iPad Air both the four and
five have had them for a while and I
want to know do they sound much better
than what seems to be the same let's go
ahead and take a listen
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
all right guys that's exactly what I
thought when I first heard the iPad 10
yes it's better than the nine but it
didn't sound that great and now we hear
that the iPad Air 5 and the air 4 not
only does it get louder the highest
frequencies are more clear The Trebles
better and the bass bumps a lot more so
the speakers are better in every single
way and the only reason I think that
could happen is if Apple used the
speakers from the iPad Mini in this new
iPad 10 whereas the main drivers from
the iPad Pro are in the iPad Air so the
difference is pretty significant and now
let's talk about apple pencil support
the iPad Air 4 and 5 supports the apple
pencil 2 which has a nicer shape it
supports uh functions when you tap it it
magnetically attaches to charge and to
connect to your iPad or pair and you can
draw with very little latency or lag
especially with that laminated display
the experience is quite good a lot
better than when I tested the Gen 1
yesterday now with the iPad 10 Apple
made some very weird choices first off
you saw there was no magnet there before
and they are supporting only the
original apple pencil from 2015 that is
not only a lot worse technically but it
has that lightning connector meaning
there is no way to plug it into pair or
to charge without having a separate
adapter and they do not include that
adapter in the Box you do get a nice
braided charging cable but personally
I'd rather have that nine dollar adapter
included and I can't even test this out
right now because those didn't come out
for a week after these iPads even though
I ordered right away now the performance
should be identical to the iPad 9 where
you do have some delay and some latency
so it's definitely not great and it
sucks that Apple made us choose this
option now they're including that
adapter if you buy a new apple pencil
but those are also pushed back as far as
shipping and so many people already have
these already that it sucks to have to
spend extra money to make it work now
once we get that adapter we will compare
it to the iPad Air and talk about the
performance in our full review so make
sure to click that subscribe button down
below so you don't miss that and now
let's compare the keyboards in my
previous video I said that this was also
delayed even though I pre-ordered it
right away well I was able to find one
locally which is great so let's go ahead
and open up this 250 dollar magic
keyboard folio and see how well it
performs and how it compares to the
magic keyboard well it looks nice man
looks nice oh yeah nice and white at
least while it's brand new now First
Impressions the quality is really really
good that is a strong magnetic hold it's
not going anywhere and as you guys could
see we have the white color because it
is the only color option now the
keyboard is split and it magnetically
attaches
I thought I'd be snapping stronger than
this maybe I'm slightly off here there
we go so we have the folio part where
you have this hinge to adjust your angle
and that comes up so that part of it is
nice and then you have the keyboard part
now as far as the keyboard here it feels
great just like any other Apple keyboard
and we also have this trackpad which is
very convenient turns this into a laptop
replacement device and one really nice
thing is that it has this full function
row of keys so you have quick shortcuts
so many things I love the brightness
adjustment and you can you know switch
tracks do all those things without
having to go and access your control
panel so overall this keyboard is really
nice and as far as the magnetic strength
I mean it holds on very well now for the
iPad Airs we have Apple's magic keyboard
which allows it to float up in the air
like this you'll also have adjustability
you can go lower open it up and then be
able to tilt up and that allows the
screen to be a little bit closer to your
face because it kind of hovers there is
suspended in the air as you guys can see
we have the Black Version so you can
choose whatever color you would like but
with this one we do not have a row of
function keys so you do have to go back
to the screen a lot more often the keys
do feel nice but the trackpad is
actually smaller I don't know how much
the difference is in width let's just go
ahead and place them side by side like
this it's pretty similar but the depth
of it is much shallower on the magic
keyboard because all these keys are
brought down due to that floating
functionality so that means that overall
using the trackpad is going to be better
on the iPad 10. the magic keyboard also
has an additional USB type-c port that
you can use for charging so you still
have access to the other one for
transferring files or connecting
accessories and you don't have to have a
cable sticking out of the side if you're
charging so that's definitely nice and
with that if you guys take a look at how
compact this whole bottom is compared to
the setup with the iPad 10. if you're on
an airplane or somewhere you have a lot
of room this is nice and small here you
need a lot of extra room for the
footprint of the iPad you guys let me
know which design you like better down
in the comments section but the kicker
is that instead of spending 250 dollars
compared to 300 you can get a renewed
magic keyboard on Amazon for 167 dollars
with a three month return policy which
is absolutely crazy now along with the
keyboards we have a difference in camera
placement the quality is the same but
with iPad 10 I'm looking directly at the
screen right here and it looks exactly
like it should we also have a microphone
cut out right there next to the camera
whereas with the iPad Airs I'm looking
at the same spot but it looks like I'm
looking way off from the side from the
up because the camera is on that left
hand side that I would love if the iPad
Airs and the pros they all switch to
this landscape orientation because it's
better for everybody with that let me
know if you hear any difference in terms
of microphone quality on the iPad Air or
on the iPad 10 if that sounds any better
and now let's get into performance and
see how the A14 in the iPad 10 compares
to the A14 in the iPad Air 4 and the
iPad Air 5 with the M1 now both these
have USB type-c ports but we do have
some differences in actual performance
now in yesterday's video I tested out
the iPad Air 10 and it took almost 11
minutes to transfer a file that is less
than 25 gigabytes that calculated to
just over 40 megabytes per second
meaning that the port on here even
though it's USB type c it is USB 2.0
which has now been confirmed and that is
insane for a brand new device in 2022
almost 2023 and now I'm going to test
the same exact file copying it over from
the same drive with the same cable to
the iPad Air 5. and that took 2 minutes
and 38 seconds instead of close to 11
minutes that is a massive difference in
the iPad Air 4 is also going to have the
same speed now the next thing that I
want to test is the speed of the
internal drive BMR test is started here
and look at that guys I was not
expecting that the speeds are almost
identical between them as far as read we
have 781 compared to 752 and for right
we have 272 compared to 271 and that
explains why it took 2 minutes 38
seconds instead of much faster because
we're actually limited by the 64
gigabyte model so if you have a higher
capacity the write speed will be faster
and that also confirms the USB 2 because
even with the same slow write speed
the iPad Air 5 was way faster and if we
had a higher capacity it would take
under a minute if it wasn't limiting it
by that right so that is crazy and now
let's compare the processor performance
with geekbench 5. we have the A14 here
with four gigs of RAM and the iPad Air 4
with a 14 all says 4 gigs compared to 8
gigs of RAM with the M1 chip we have our
results in as far as single core we have
a difference of only about eight percent
but for multi-core the M1 is more than
82 percent faster now the iPad Air 4
with the A14 is about 10 faster than the
iPad 10. so even if you buy one of those
refurbished ones at a lower price tag
you still get better performance now as
far as compute performance with the
graphics let's go ahead and see here the
scores it looks like the iPad 10 is just
slightly behind the iPad Air 4 with A14
but the M1 has almost 21
000 score that is 70 sent better
performance than the iPad 10. that is
crazy now as far as Graphics gaming
performance I'm using 3D Marks Wildlife
extreme in unlimited mode which allows
it to you have the same resolution it's
on screen so it's perfectly fair and wow
we have 28.9 frames per second for the
M1 compared to 12.2 and the iPad Air 4
at the A14 is higher than 14 FPS so it
gets about 10 faster graphics
performance even though it is the same
chip so if you care about gaming I mean
this is a massive difference now I don't
only want to do these benchmarks I want
to test some real world usage so here I
have let your mobile opened up with some
raw images these have all been color
graded they've been edited they have
effects added there's 50 42 megapixel
raw files and I'm going to go ahead and
Export all of these to jpegs and the M1
iPad Air is flying there you go both of
them are done we now have all the photos
here saved full quality and the M1 iPad
Air took 4 minutes and 18 seconds while
as the A14 iPad Well that took 8 minutes
and 36 seconds so the M1 iPad Air is
basically twice as fast and I think if
we had the upgraded storage it would be
even faster now what about video editing
here I have a five minute cut of my
project where I compared the s22 Ultras
108 megapixels to the iPhone's 48. if
you guys haven't seen this video you
guys absolutely have to see it I'm gonna
go ahead and add a filter to this that
way the iPads have a little bit more
work to do than just taking this 4K and
encoding it and now let's go ahead and
Export this 4K video now looking at this
status bar here the M1 iPad isn't that
far ahead of the A14 iPad bam the M1
iPad is done and this one is just a
little bit behind they were neck in your
neck for a while and this slowed down
maybe because the chip is throttling uh
as far as the graphics I'm not sure and
that took two minutes and 55 seconds on
the M1 iPad Air and 3 minutes and 24
seconds on the A14 so not really much of
a difference there and if you had the
iPad Air 4 that also has the A14 it
would be similar to this now why is the
iPad so much faster in photos but not in
video well that's because we're still
limited by the encoders and the M1 chip
uses the same ones as the A14 so for
video editors it's not going to be a
massive difference unless you're doing
crazy crazy effects and now let's talk
about battery life a lot of people ask
about this and it's very interesting for
this scenario the actual battery
capacities are practically the same for
both iPad Airs and the iPad 10
generation but what I found found is
when you're charging them the highest
that I saw the attention iPad reach is
24 Watts whereas we hit 30 Watts on the
iPad Air so that means apple is capping
the wattage for some reason I don't know
why but it will charge about 25 slower
so it's going to take longer now as far
as the actual battery life themselves uh
Apple gives you very vague ratings but
the M1 version of the iPad could
potentially get better battery life if
you're just doing very light loads very
easy tasks but if you start doing things
that really maximize all that
performance that you guys saw from the
previous tests well then it will drain
faster so it's kind of a wash but of
course I'd rather have it drained faster
and give you my results better give you
better results faster exports better
gaming and then be able to charge it
also 25 faster now some of you guys were
wondering about Wi-Fi speeds the specs
are very vague so I went ahead and I ran
it here and we see that the M1 iPad does
have faster download speeds connected
same network everything same but the
uploads were slower quite slow on both
actually so I don't know if it's better
range in general but these are the
results so overall is the iPad 10 really
worth 450 dollars when you can buy an
iPad Air either the M1 version or the
A14 version that's actually less money
if it's refurbished and you can get the
keyboard case also for less money
personally I do not think so now I
really like the landscape camera and if
that's important to you then that is a
really nice feature but the iPad Airs
either one of them are better in so many
ways not being limited by that Port
having better performance even with the
same A14 chip having that laminated
display makes a massive difference in
reflectivity in contrast asked the
speakers are quite a bit better I mean
it's a better device in almost every way
now if this iPad was 399 or 350 it would
be a whole nother story but since Apple
jacked the price up so much and since
you can get an iPad Air for a discount
especially the refurbished model it just
makes way more sense to me to go that
direction we're gonna have links down
below you guys let me know your thoughts
click that Circle above to subscribe if
you want to see our full review after we
use this for regular personal use check
out one of those great videos right
there this is Max and I'll see you in
the next video
foreign